For centuries, before refrigeration, an old
Russian practice was to drop a frog into a
bucket of milk to keep the milk from spoiling.
In modern times, many believed that this was
nothing more than an old wives’ tale.
But researchers at Moscow State University,
led by organic chemist Dr. Albert Lebedev,
have shown that there could be some benefit
to doing this, though of course in the end
you’ll be drinking milk that a frog was
in.
Ice boxes first became available to consumers
in the early to mid-19th century and, with
that, the ice trade became big business.
New England and Norway became major purveyors
of ice, but anywhere it was cold, ice was
a major export.
Usually made out of wood with tin or zinc
walls and insulation material like sawdust,
cork, or straw, ice boxes were popular until
they were rendered obsolete by the electrical
refrigerator starting around the 1930s.
Jacob Perkins invented the first version of
the refrigerator in 1834 when it was discovered
that the hazardous compound ammonia, when
liquefied, had a cooling effect.
But it wasn’t until the late 1920s when
Freon was developed by General Motors and
DuPont as a “nontoxic” cooling agent,
and replaced ammonia, that refrigerators for
consumers started to gain traction.
Despite the prevalence of ice in parts of
Russia, in certain small rural Russian villages
many didn’t have access to ice boxes, so
they had to find ways to keep things cold
and unspoiled.
A practice developed, that continued into
the 20th century, as described by Dr. Lebedev
from memories from his childhood,
[For] small portions of milk to drink, they
used to put [a] frog inside…
A small frog over there could prevent the
milk from being spoiled.
This rather curious practice was an inspiration
for a study and, then, a discovery that may
lead to a significant new source of antibiotics.
In 2010, scientists from United Arab Emirates
University made an announcement that the secretions
from certain frogs’ skins have antibacterial
and antifungal properties.
Using species native to African countries,
they studied the compounds coming from the
frogs, which are known as antimicrobial peptides
and are a string of amino acids.
After isolating these compounds, they began
testing them against various bacterial infections.
For example, the dreaded “Iraqibacter,”
a drug-resistant bacterial infection that
has been known to hit wounded soldiers in
Iraq could (once again, potentially) be fought
with a compound found in the skin of a mink
frog that are native to North America.
Secretions from a foothill four-legged frog
may have the potential to fight the well-known
resistant MRSA staph skin infection.
In 2012, scientists from Moscow State University
decided to take this a step further by breaking
down the compounds and studying the individual
peptides.
In a study entitled “Composition and Antimicrobial
Activity of Skin Peptidome of Russian Brown
Frogs” published in the Journal of Proteome
Research in November 2012, and using Russian
brown frogs (which are edible and considered
a delicacy), they extracted secretions by
applying electrodes.
What came out was a cocktail of 76 different
peptides that all had different properties.
Michael Zasloff, now a professor at Georgetown
University, but formerly a researcher with
the National Institutes of Health said in
an interview that, “What is amazing is that
no two frogs have the same cocktail.
They’re all different, and all beautifully
tuned to deal with the microbes that these
animals face.”
As promising as the results are so far, many
scientists are skeptical of any real benefit
coming from them.
For instance, Jun O. Liu, a professor of pharmacology
at John Hopkins University School of Medicine,
stated in reference to other apparent natural
occurring “magic antibiotics,” “There
are natural substances that work in a lab
beautifully but then when you give it to a
human it’s totally inactive or it’s toxic.”
While this all may or may not ultimately be
medicinally helpful for humans, beginning
centuries ago certain Russians seem to have
been on to something with putting frogs in
milk to delay it spoiling.
Although, I think we can all agree that putting
a frog in one’s milk takes a back seat to
the other age-old way to store milk without
refrigeration- making it into delicious cheese.